10 Cloverfield Lane tells a small story designed
to stand on its own, but it's also deceptively
full of complex plot twists, potent but understated
themes, and a few hidden ties to a larger
Cloverfield mythology.
Let's unlock this bunker of secrets and explain
the ending of 10 Cloverfield Lane.
Though they seem to have nothing in common
on the surface, a look back at Cloverfield
may provide some clues about the aims of 10
Cloverfield Lane.
The original movie is about a giant monster's
arrival in New York City, but that's just
a backdrop to the main drama.
Through its found footage conceit, Cloverfield
showcases a group of twenty-somethings sending
off their friend Rob as he prepares to move
to Japan to start a new job.
Cloverfield's inventive first-person angle
on a classic Godzilla formula makes it an
effective thrill ride, but it's the naturalistic
depiction of young adults in 2008 America
that gives it a surprising amount of weight.
In short, it's a giant sci-fi blockbuster
interrupting an intimate indie drama about
people struggling with regret.
Their perspectives are shaken and shaped by
unimaginable horror, making their real needs
clear for the first time.
That brings us to the sequel.
10 Cloverfield Lane introduces us to a heroine
in a hurry.
In the opening sequence, Michelle is anxiously
packing a suitcase, her eyes darting to the
stormy horizon outside.
Is she desperate to escape a monster invasion?
As it turns out, she's fleeing from an ill-fated
proposal and ignoring calls from her boyfriend.
Leaving behind an engagement ring and taking
a bottle of whiskey, she hits the highway
out of New Orleans.
In the midst of the drama that will soon follow,
it might be easy to lose track of just how
much is being set up about Michelle's character
here.
The fashion sketches seen strewn around her
apartment, the radio news reports about massive
blackouts, and even the bottle of whiskey
are all elements that will pay off later.
Most importantly, we learn from her boyfriend's
call that she has an apparent chronic problem
with commitment.
It's clear that his words strike a chord with
her, as she grows increasingly distracted
listening to his voice from behind the wheel.
“We had an argument, couples fight.
That's no reason to just leave everything
behind.
Running away isn't going to help."
So distracted, in fact, that she's unprepared
for the truck that sideswipes her into a violent
wreck.
Michelle wakes up in a strange cinderblock
room that's half grey and half painted pink
in some sort of sad attempt at cheerful femininity.
She's hooked up to an IV drip and her leg,
injured in the crash, is in a brace.
But the brace is chained to the wall — someone
has saved her life, but is also holding her
captive.
That someone is Howard Stambler.
Howard soon explains that he's taken Michelle
into his private underground bunker in the
aftermath of some sort of attack.
He's fuzzy on the details, muttering theories
about everything from Russians to Martians.
Howard has known for years that something
was coming, though, and has been preparing
for this day for years.
Michelle's room, we gradually learn, was supposed
to be for his daughter, Megan.
Why isn't Megan here instead?
According to Howard, her mother turned her
against him.
It's an explanation couched in the disturbingly
familiar language of abuse.
Before she can come to any conclusions about
whether or not she trusts Howard, Michelle
becomes aware of a third person in their midst.
Emmett is a young man who helped build Howard's
bunker and made his way to it as soon as loud
sounds and lights in the sky signaled the
onslaught of whatever invasion has occurred.
Friendly and naïve, Emmett quickly becomes
Michelle's ally in solving the bunker's mysteries.
It may not be immediately clear, but Emmett
serves a few functions in the story.
His most obvious purpose is to give Michelle
support and someone to talk to as she navigates
her situation.
He also provides some important exposition,
informing Michelle that Howard was always
known for his doomsday prepper mentality and
eventually sharing an important revelation
about a photo that Howard claims is of his
daughter, Megan.
Most ominously, it's significant that Howard
seems to barely tolerate Emmett's presence.
Howard's consistent irritation toward Emmett
suggests that he has more specific goals with
the bunker than saving lives.
Unsurprisingly, Michelle remains hesitant
to trust the man who chained her to a wall
and told her Martians may have attacked.
She remains not entirely convinced by his
stories, even after he brings her to the bunker's
heavy, locked door to show her a pair of mutilated
pigs outside, as evidence of what the air
itself will do to anyone who breathes it.
So, at the first opportunity, she bashes him
in the head, grabs his keys, and makes a break
for the door.
But before she can open it, she's met by a
woman begging to be let in, screaming and
desperate as the skin seemingly melts from
her face.
Fully convinced that the air outside is indeed
dangerous, Michelle resigns herself to remaining
in the bunker.
The decision is made easier by a seemingly
softened attitude from Howard, who talks her
through the process of stitching up the head
injury she caused while sharing stories about
his time in the Navy.
They soon enough move on from the disturbing
death they've witnessed, but the memory lingers
over the film until the very end.
As the only two people who can relate to each
other, Michelle and Emmett naturally end up
sharing stories about their lives before the
bunker.
They talk about tattoos they've always wanted,
with Emmett saying that he would've gotten
plenty if he'd known that the "attack" was
going to happen.
When asked if he has any regrets, Howard replies:
"Everything I wanted to do, I did.
I focused on being prepared, and I was.
And here we are."
Later, after the occurrence with the woman
at the door, Emmett tries to comfort Michelle
by assuring her that there was nothing she
could've done to help.
This brings up more talk of regrets — Michelle
is haunted by the time she saw a little girl
being abused by her father and did nothing
to help, while Emmett's life was changed when
a lack of confidence stopped him from getting
on a bus to start college at Louisiana Tech.
Michelle and Emmett settle in for life with
Howard, though the peace remains uneasy.
In a particularly uncomfortable game night,
Howard fails to associate the word "woman"
with Michelle, struggling with words like
"girl" and "princess."
It's a disturbing indication of how much he's
infantilized her.
The tension comes to a head when Michelle,
tasked with crawling through the bunker's
vents to fix an air filter, discovers a window
to the outside into which someone has scratched
the word "HELP."
Nearby, she finds a bloody earring, which
she recognizes from Howard's photo of Megan.
But when she shows the picture to Emmett,
he recognizes the girl not as Megan, but as
a classmate of his little sister's who disappeared
from the area some time back.
Regardless of how correct he might be about
the dangers outside, it's now clear to Michelle
and Emmett how dangerous Howard is.
He's been using the bunker to hold young women
captive in a deluded attempt to replace his
daughter — and Michelle is next.
Michelle has a plan.
She envisions a makeshift hazmat suit constructed
from the bunker's shower curtain and various
household items.
She and Emmett begin assembling the materials
while evading Howard's notice.
Unfortunately, it doesn't work for long, and
Howard calls the two of them to help him move
a barrel.
Inside the barrel is an acid capable of dissolving
human bodies down to the bone.
Howard makes it clear that he knows that Michelle
and Emmett are up to something, and that if
they don't confess, they'll end up in the
barrel.
Emmett accepts all responsibility for the
plan, and Howard accepts his apology by calmly
shooting him in the head.
Howard insists to a shocked Michelle that,
like everything else, he's done this to protect
her.
Soon after, he undergoes some sort of bizarre
Dad Transformation, appearing clean-shaven
and neatly-dressed for the first time as he
offers Michelle ice cream.
The uneasy tension of his demeanor has been
replaced by an even more terrifying sense
of total, unchallenged delusion.
But Michelle's real call to action comes in
a silent scene that finds her going through
Emmett's belongings and finding the bus tickets
to Louisiana Tech he'd been holding onto for
all these years.
Her resolve is bolstered.
With the uncertainty of the world outside,
leaving the bunker is less about saving her
own life than it is about not letting regret
define her death.
The film's climax kicks off when Howard discovers
Michelle's nearly complete hazmat suit, and
she narrowly escapes his wrath by momentarily
trapping him in her room.
When he breaks free and corners her near the
perchloric acid, she has no choice but to
push a barrel over, starting a fire as soon
as the acid hits an electrical outlet.
Fleeing through the vents from a burned and
furious Howard, Michelle uses the can of liquid
nitrogen to break the exit's massive padlock
and at last escape.
This final flight out of the bunker is fast
and intense, but a careful retracing of the
movie's plot reveals just how much of it has
been set up all along.
Michelle has successfully constructed a hazmat
suit, thanks to her interest in fashion design
that's part of her character from the very
beginning.
Her knowledge of the ventilation layout is
established by the earlier filter repair sequence
— one of the film's most intense moments
in its own right.
And the liquid nitrogen trick was subtly foreshadowed
by Howard's casual aside about doing the same
thing in the Navy.
Michelle has spent her time in captivity learning
everything she needed to survive.
In the open air of Howard's farm, Michelle
briefly panics when a hole tears in her suit.
But the sight of birds flocking overhead,
unharmed, tips her off that the air may not
be as toxic as she believed.
Sure enough, she removes her makeshift plastic
bottle facemask and can breathe without trouble.
But then a horn sounds nearby, alerting her
to the presence of an enormous alien craft
sailing over the crops.
As darkness falls, another ship rises up from
behind the house, and an enormous tentacled
beast emerges.
Michelle takes shelter in Howard's truck,
and though the creature lifts it up and nearly
devours her, she has one more trick up her
sleeve — and it's yet another plot point
set up in the movie's earliest scenes.
With the bottle of whiskey she took with her
when she left home, she fashions a Molotov
cocktail that not only burns the alien, but
causes a chain reaction with the gases in
its body, obliterating the monster in a huge
explosion.
The most important reason for 10 Cloverfield
Lane's surprise final sequence, though, is
to bring Michelle's character arc to a significant
final moment.
She commandeers the car left behind by the
woman at the bunker's door, at first following
radio instructions for survivors to gather
at Baton Rouge.
Her escape is interrupted by another radio
message:
"But if you have any medical training or combat
experience, we need help."
Silently reflecting on how everything that's
happened to her has given her exactly the
necessary skills, she turns toward Houston,
as stormy skies reveal more ships looming
in the distance.
The movie ends on this moment of decision,
with our heroine barreling toward danger.
It's far more than open-ended sequel setup,
however.
It's the first time Michelle has committed
to facing a problem head on instead of running
from danger or difficulty.
We've watched her go from a scared, uncertain
person racked with regret to a decisive, competent
hero ready to give herself over to a noble
cause.
Everything about her time in the bunker, her
battle with Howard, and her honesty with Emmett
has brought her to this place.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.